المكان الوحيد الذي يمكنني أن أذهب إليه من هنا
هو
لأن هذا
ربما يكون واحدًا من أقل الأماكن تأثيرًا على
بولينا بو توريس هي مؤثرة تبلغ من العمر 20 عامًا
ولديها ملايين المتابعين
الذين يحبون مقاطع الفيديو الممتعة الخاصة بها على Tick
Tock و YouTube وقد تواصلت معي CNN
ولكن بعد  انفصلت هي وصديقها البالغ من العمر ثلاث
سنوات ، ووثقت ستة
أشهر من البؤس لها ونشرت أنه على
YouTube أيضًا كنت خائفًا جدًا من نشر مقطع
فيديو كنت متوترة حقًا لأنك
تعلم أن الناس يمكن أن يكونوا لئيمين جدًا عبر الإنترنت عن
شيء يتعلق بصدقها الخام.
أبعد بكثير من قاعدة متابعيها
وكانت تتجه في غضون 24 ساعة ولكن
الشيء هو أنني لم أرغب في الشفقة ، أعتقد أن
الجميع يبكي كما تعلم ، لذلك كان الأمر
مثلي تمامًا عندما أشارك تلك اللحظات الضعيفة ،
لكنني أيضًا أشارك كيف مررت
بتلك اللحظات.  لقد صنعت مقطع
الفيديو بعد مشاهدة الآخرين مثله
على الإنترنت ،
وفي الواقع هناك سبب لوجود مقاطع فيديو
حول الانفصال ، تقول
عالمة الأنثروبولوجيا الدكتورة هيلين فيشر أنك تعلم أننا
عشنا في كوخ صغير في
مجموعات التجمع لملايين السنين
وكنت مع حوالي 25 شخصًا كل يوم
طوال  الوقت ولذا لدينا رغبة طبيعية
في المشاركة ، فهناك جزء في الفيديو
كان يوم 14 سبتمبر وكنت
أشعر بالوحدة فقط وأردت حقًا أن
أرسل له رسالة مفادها أنني أفتقده ولكني لا
أريد أن أفعل ذلك له  لأنني أعلم
أنه ليس مفيدًا لأي منا الذي أشعر به
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالانفصال في كثير من
الأحيان ، فهو شديد السمية ولكنني أردت
أن أوضح أنه لا يوجد مثلك يعرف أنه
ليس دائمًا على هذا النحو وأنه
يجعله في الواقع  من الصعب حقًا عندما
تعلم أن هذا الشخص شخص جيد ، لقد
تأثرت بشدة مع بولينا ،
فهي لا تلعب دور الضحية التي كانت
تقولها ، انظر إليّ من خلال
هذا الأمر ، يمكنك تجاوز هذا أيضًا
كجزء من عملها في العديد من الدراسات د.
قامت فيشر وفريقها بمسح أدمغة
أكثر من 100 شخص لمعرفة
كيف نتغلب على هذا ولماذا
كل هذا مؤلم للغاية أعتقد أن
الحب الرومانسي يمكن أن يكون إدمانًا رائعًا تمامًا
عندما يكون على ما يرام
وإدمانًا رهيبًا تمامًا عندما يكون.
تسير بشكل سيء ، وبالفعل ، فإن إحدى
مناطق الدماغ الثلاثة المرتبطة بالشغف
والإدمان هي أيضًا منطقة دماغية
تجعلك تبدأ في محاولة
معرفة مكاسبك وخسائرك هل
فقدت أطفالًا هل فقدت حيوانات أليفة هل
فقدت منزلي
ولكن ماذا  لقد خسروا وقتًا حقيقيًا
بالنسبة إلى Paulina ، كانت هناك لعبة كبيرة
أشعر حقًا أنني أستطيع إلقاء نظرة على
العلاقة ورؤية الأشياء بشكل
مختلف تمامًا ، وأود أن أقول إن اللحظة المفضلة لدي
في الفيديو كانت عندما
أدركت نوعًا ما أنني  كان
آمنًا بالفعل ولم أكن بحاجة إلى
علاقة ولم أكن بحاجة إلى شخص ما
لإكمالني لأنه لم يكن هناك
شيء مفقود في نفسي
نعم
أجنبي